even if you have stuff anything and I
just gave the numbers to some people you
probably gotten find out that we can now
start to observe what's going on with
this factorization thing and why what do
you know the fact is is something once
you break it down you understand that
number better I want you to look at the
number of factors if you've got for the
pair of numbers it can have you got the
whole here's a way that you can check
for example you can see that we outlined
24 spools up another we can pretty much
a nail it more than one go okay you all
know you've got the mobile because you
can see the factors coming pairs right
the factors coming paired so one in
24-hour care because one times 24 is 24
two and twelve are pair three and eight
four and six
okay so this is the one of the ways that
you can check in one of your numbers
doesn't have a pair and opposite then I
bet you have a square number right
because for example if you have if you
have 64 0 so 64 so 64 will have a number
that is right in the middle and doesn't
have a pair to go with namely think
about it it's going to be 8 because 8
goes with it so does that make sense but
everyone else should have a list like
this ok now immediately you've all
noticed something if you just listen
carefully to what I've just said 64 Java
ketones the factors of 64 have you got
okay now you remember we said everything
should pair up all your factors should
pair up like this unless you have a
square number right in which case the
square root will be on its own okay do
you notice them have a look count up the
number of factors you have for your
number
do you notice all that we have an even
number of factors
she knows that unless of course you have
square e the only ones that are credibly
bottom down okay keep that in your mind
now I actually want you to pay closer
attention to the actual number of
factors that you've got so for instance
24 has 8 factors you can see them all
there how many people have a number
we've got mean factors they don't handle
with anybody what do you have for it
someone give me another day 56 you have
to scale it 60 see anyone else gonna get
48 and we should have won again 54 okay
so I'm trying to understand just like in
the periodic table right you've got
numbers they seem to come up at some
frequency and they have this similar
property they almost seem to have a
factors and I could do this process
again for all the lungs which are six
items all the numbers which have all
factors and so on I'm trying to get at
why is it that these numbers I'm going
to write in the proper order
why is it the B numbers all have 48 54
56 66 and I have 24 in a twist as well
why is it a big numbers all have eight
factors what's going on
I asked you the first thing to write
down the prime factorization of the
numbers I already got the protractor
initial columns 24 on the bottom is 2
cubed times 3
David 40 our food at pier 14 sorry yeah
doesn't 2 cubed times 548 choose the
failure yeah I think if you have the
extra factor we'll come back to this one
actually 2 to the 4 times 3 30 f/16
we'll come back to this guy in a second
and why it's different 54 then again 3
cubed times 256 to in person
and because it
two times six times 11 there right okay
leave 48 to one side for a second
because control number factors would
come back to it in a minute
24:40 54 56 66 they all have a factors
hmm a bunch of them have some
significant things in common do you
notice it's what do you see for example
if you have a look at 1 2 3 4 what he
knows
yeah they are they're all they all
include a cube and then some other
number did you notice that so you can't
have a cube by itself unique you add
something else to note that and only how
many something else is do you have just
1 3 5 to 7 okay so there's a pattern
there is a patent bit you might sort of
conclude from that okay I think
everything cute times one other number
has 8 factors under how you could test
that out look at other but then you've
got this guy which seems to break our
patent what's going on this guy has
eight factors as well but it's not in
this format so what's happening okay the
factorization is the key factorization
is the key 24 we've got these factors
laid out like this because they're all
written there I like everyone else's I'm
going to use this as my example okay 2
cubed times 3 actually 3 to the 1 and I
want to teach you a bit of magic it's
going to imagine for about 6 or 7
minutes until you understand how it
works
and then it becomes known about it if I
have a look at these two powers up here
3 & 1 I'm going to increase both powers
by 1 which gives me 4 & 2
what's 4 times 2
four times two is eight which is the
number of fat is the 24 has 66 wonder
powers 1 and 1 and what the kalman do
the same trick I'm going to increase all
the cards by 1 which gives me 2 2 + 2
which is a which is the number of
factors at 66 pounds seems like magic
doesn't
which is why 48 doesn't have eight
batters how many factors would you
anticipate that it has 10 because the
powers are 4 and 1 so I'm going to
increase them to 5 into 5 times 2 is
there are 10 factors now this is magic
right now what on earth is going on let
me show you
it's about this structure ok have a look
at each of these factors do you notice
if I want to turn one going to I could
write each of them and their prime
factorization because then all prized
you notice that so for example I could
do the prime factor there to the 12 and
a 6 and so on okay if you do that you
reveal a structure can you all draw a
table for me we're going to need 3
columns and
fibers
in fact is a not randomly arranged they
not randomly arranged at all each of
them in the combination of the prime
factors okay so for example do you
notice a bunch of the factors of 24 are
even how many of them are even exactly
how many two four six eight twelve
twenty-four like the other ones right
why are you so many even ones because
there are many twos in the prime
factorization okay look again how many
of them are multiples of three exactly
half of them right what the ones that
are multiples are great
Riis multiple three and six and 12 and
24 right these are all multiples of
three what are all the other ones at all
of the other factors these factors
divided by three okay
you see there this patentee how do i
form this grid of numbers well these are
all of the ones that are multiples of 3
or I should say multiples of 3 the power
of 1 right these are not multiples of 3
then also the 3 power 0
this is a multiple of two these are all
multiples up to look at the numbers to
square these are all multiples of two
cubes these guys are not multiples of
two these are the only two ones that
aren't even like you notice the rest of
them the other six are even these are
multiples of two to that
do you remember I said you have to take
those powers these guys up here and you
had to for some reason I didn't explain
you had to add one to the pouch you had
to bump them up remember that why do I
bought them up what was that what was
the bumping up is it's these guys right
you have to include them because they
contribute factors as well okay and this
is why it's going to be this wide into
66 okay you can't do on a piece of paper
that's flat anyway you can't do a grid
that's going to have all three you
actually the cube to do that which would
be 2 times 2 times 2
okay still get 8 whatever this happens
to be so rewind a little bit
my way of saying all of this is just to
establish factorization you learn this
in your normal mathematics class as just
a process that we have to do and you get
quite good of it and you guys don't
usually question why you have to do it
because you're quite right is it right
but you have to understand why are you
doing this what does factorization give
you answer it I want the structure of a
number right just like the periodic
table on lots of the structure of an
element that tells you how it works